We are now ready to develop
a Spectral Alignment Algorithm, and
we will capitalize on the observation
that a modification corresponds to either
block insertion, or
block deletion in the Peptide vector.
And, therefore, maybe we can us
an analogy with sequence alignment,
where "alignment" corresponds to
the minimum of insertion, deletion, and
substitutions of amino acids.
So, our goal is to figure out
whether we can find similarities between
Peptide vector, and Spectrum vector
by finding a longest path in a properly
constructed spectral alignment graph.
The only question is
how to construct this graph.
Let's start.
In the beginning, let's construct
first a graph that I call
Southeast(m,m+delta),
which consists of a grid
with m+1 rows and m+delta+1 columns.
Edges in this graph will
simply correspond to all edges
going in the Southeast direction.
And given that peptide a_1,...,a_m of mass m
and its modified variant peptide^mod
a'_1,...,a'_n
of mass m+delta,
we can construct a path formed by this Peptide,
Peptide and Peptide',
in the graph Southeast(m,m+delta),
and such path is shown in this graph.
So this blue path corresponds
to a modified Peptide with
two modifications, shown in blue here,
and this red path corresponds to a Peptide
with three modifications,
shown in red here.
So far, I failed to explain how
to construct a path between
an unmodified Peptide, in green here, and
its modified version, shown in blue here.
Let me do this now.
So this path will start
at the the node (0,0),
then move to the node with the coordinate
equal to the masses of
prefixes of length 1 of this Peptide,
then move to the coordinate corresponding
to masses of prefixes of length 2,
and finally, move to the node with
coordinate corresponding to
the masses of the entire unmodified
and modified Peptides.
We will also distinguish between two
types of edges in the resulting graph.
The ones that are showed by dashed edges
are non-diagonal edges, and these
are edges corresponding to modifications.
They are non-diagonal because
modification has happened.
And this is an example of a diagonal edge.
There is no modification, and the masses
of amino acids in the unmodified Peptide
and in modified Peptide are the same.
So, we will consider different
paths in the Southeast(m,m+delta)
and, in fact,
any Peptide with mass m+delta
will correspond to a path
in the Southeast graph.
Moreover, we can substitute these paths
by a Spectral vector, with mass m+delta.
And therefore, any possible interpretation
of a Spectral vector with mass
m+delta will correspond
to a path in this graph.
Therefore, I will rename
this Southeast graph
into the graph that is denoted
Southeast(Peptide,Spectrum),
and moreover, I will remove all light rows
from this graph, because I don't need them.
All paths corresponding to a
pair of unmodified and
modified Peptides traverse
only dark rows in this graph.
And therefore,
all light rows can be safely removed.
The resulting graph will be called
PSMGraph(Peptide,Spectrum),
which is defined as the graph
where the weights of all
nodes in column i are equal to the i-th
coordinate in the Spectrum vector,
and the rows in this graph,
it's important to note,
have indices not equal to 0, 1, 2, 3,
but equal to 0, mass(a1), mass(a1a2), ..., and
masses of prefixes of
the unmodified Peptide.
And, in this formulation,
the score between the modified Peptide,
and Spectrum is simply the weight
of the path for the modified Peptide.
And, therefore, we have reduced
the spectral alignment problem
to the following problem in the PSMGraph:
Given PSMGraph(Peptide,Spectrum)
and an integer k,
we want to find a maximum-weight
path in this graph
with at most k non-diagonal edges.
Well, we already know how to search for
a maximum-weight path.
But how would you search for
a maximum-weight path
with an additional constraint that
it has at most k non-diagonal edges.
To find an optimal path in
the PSMGraph with an additional
constraints on the number
of non-diagonal edges k,
we will construct yet
another graph, which is called
the Spectral Alignment Graph.
This graph will have k+1 layers,
and each layer will be
identical to the PSMGraph.
Weights of nodes in
the Spectral Alignment Graph,
will be simply inherited from
the nodes in the PSMGraph.
Now, this graph on the right
side of the slide,
Spectrum Alignment Graph,
is currently disconnected.
There are no edges connecting the
different layers of this graph.
We will connect layers of
this graph in the following way:
Diagonal edges from the PSMGraph
will stay on the same layer.
For example, the blue edge stays
on the same layer in this case.
But non-diagonal edges from the PSMGraph
will move to the next layer,
like in the case of the non-diagonal
red edge, on the right of the slide.
Now, for the case of the next pair
of edges, the same rule applies.
And finally, for every path in
the original PSMGraph, we will have
a path in the Spectral Alignment Graph
going through multiple layers,
and the spectral alignment
problem is now reformulated as
finding paths in the k-layer
Spectral Alignment Graph,
and our goal is to find
a maximum-weight path in this graph.
Before you implement
the Spectral Alignment challenge,
let me clarify some
implementation details for you.
I will introduce the notion
of the diff array.
The diff array will simply represent
differences in the indexes
of consecutive rows in the PSMGraph.
For example,
diff(2) = 2-0 = 2
diff(5) = 5-2 = 3
And here, all the elements
of the diff array are presented.
Now, to solve a longest path problem
in the spectral alignment graph,
we will define the variable score(i,j,t),
which is the maximum weight
of paths from (0,0,0),
the source of this
graph, to the node (i,j,t).
And node (i,j,t) has just one
predecessor in the same layer,
and we can compute the coordinates
of this node using the diff array.
And it has j predecessors
in the previous layer, and
we also can compute the coordinates
of these nodes using the diff array.
Therefore, score(i,j,k)
can be defined as the
s_j + maximum
over all predecessors,
score(predecessor)
To be more precise, we will use
the diff array to specify the exact
element of this recurrence.
And, of course, the maximum score of all
Peptide with at most k modifications
is simply the maximum value
of score(m,m+delta,t) for
all possible t, represented by
green nodes in this graph.
After you learned about so many algorithms
from computational proteomics,
the time has come to address
the challenge problem for this chapter.
In the same paper where Azara presented T-Rex peptides,
they also presented mastodon peptides, and
we want you to re-analyze them from the
perspective of statistical significance.
It actually has never been done.
There is nothing surprising about
finding collagen peptides in mastodons
because mastodons roamed the Earth,
just 10,000 years ago.
They went extinct because
of the climate change and
over-hunting by humans armed
with stone weapons.
So, we want you to analyze the mastodon
peptides reported in this paper
and decide which of them
are statistically significant.
We want you do find other statistically
significant mastodon peptides
that this paper possibly missed.
And we want you to find
hemoglobin peptides, if you can,
matching spectra from mastodons.